und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
in allen guten abend keine impfung unter
16 so gilt das bislang das soll sich
aber ändern
die firmen biontech pfizer haben heute
den antrag gestellt dass ihr impfstoff
in europa auch für kinder und
jugendliche von zwölf bis 15 zugelassen
wird
wenn die zulassung schnell kommt könnte
es schon im juni losgehen
laut dem bundesgesundheitsminister
spätestens in den sommerferien
damit eröffnen sich ganz neue chancen im
kampf gegen die pandemie
es stellen sich aber auch neue fragen
und es gibt natürlich auch sorgen
wir sprechen darüber gleich im detail
erst petra otto über ein thema dass
eltern und kinder umtreibt
schon das erste mal gegen korona geimpft
mit gerade mal 17 felix huber hat eine
chronische darmerkrankung sein
immunsystem ist geschwächt deshalb ist
er schon dran und im glück ich habe halt
immer so im kopf gehabt dass es da schon
so eine gewisse gefahr da ist ich bin ja
einer der wenigen was meine schuld jetzt
gift ist und das hat schon eine große
bedeutung für mich noch eine gewisse
sicherheit und ich freue mich in erster
linie haben wir richtig daniel foul
kinderarzt in stuttgart corona
schwerpunktpraxis kann sich kaum retten
vor anfragen seit sich herumgesprochen
hat dass er impfstoff bekommt für
chronisch kranke jugendliche wenn auch
viel zu wenig natürlich auch noch
limitiert weil wir wollen wir unsere
jugendlichen impfen ab 16
sondern eben alle chroniker schon mit
dem felix geschützt aber vieles hinaus
2014 haben chronische kranke sind
gefährdet nun gibt es hoffnung auch für
jüngere kinder wenn bei montech die
zulassung von der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur bekommt schon für
zwölfjährige dann könnten vielleicht in
einigen wochen die ersten impfungen von
schülern starten
studien mit kleineren kindern sogar
säuglingen laufen auch da sollen bald
ergebnisse auf dem tisch liegen
impfstoffe testen an minderjährigen
juristisch schwierig trotzdem werden an
vielen orten der welt fast alle corona
impfstoffe auch an kindern
und er sucht kinder sind keine kleinen
erwachsenen und muss erstmal
herausfinden welches die richtige dosis
für den jeweiligen impfstoff ist und
dann die verträglichkeit sich anschauen
kleine kinder gegen korona impfen auch
eine ethische frage
fast alle haben leichte verläufe wo zu
dämpfen ersten zwei kinder auch anrecht
auf impfschutz haben
zweitens weil es viele kinder gibt die
grundkrankheiten haben und die bei coop
19 erkrankung eine zusätzliche bürde
haben
und drittens weil wir uns in einer
pandemie befinden
und da brauche man eben auch die kinder
sagen viele wissenschaftler für den
herdenschutz doch der ist manchen eltern
längst nicht so wichtig wie das eigene
kind wenn ich es haben dann denke ich
einfach einmal durchmachen
auch sowas mit grundschutz hat muss sie
nicht sonst häufig dagegen geimpft
werden ich finde die kindergartens
erscheinen dass die korona die krone in
hama
und zweitens sind mir die risiken
einfach zu hoch felix zögerte keine
sekunde sich impfen zu lassen eine last
ist von ihnen gefallen er traut sich
wieder unter menschen mit der impfung
rückt die freiheit ein stück näher
nicht nur für ihn der stellvertretende
direktor der kinder uniklinik münchen
ist jetzt bei uns der vorsitzende der
deutschen gesellschaft für pädiatrische
infektiologie professor johannes hübner
professor genannt guten abend herr
sievers wir wissen kinder sind nicht
einfach kleine erwachsene wissen sie
denn bereits jetzt genug über wirkung
und folgen einer corona impfung für
kinder
also da gibt es ja jetzt ganz aktuell
die ersten ergebnisse einer studie die
preise durchgeführt hat da gibt es
bisher nur presseberichte wir haben dann
sehr wenig informationen darüber was wir
bisher wissen ist aber sehr
vielversprechend also die impfung bei
sehr sehr gut wirksam die antikörper
titer gut die verträglichkeit war kein
problem also ich denke das sind sehr
gute voraussetzungen
jetzt haben die kinder noch ihr ganzes
leben vor sich und
es gibt durchaus eltern die sagen ja
also bei den normalen regel impfungen
bin ich immer dabei aber jetzt bei so
einem neuen impfstoff da bin ich doch
eher vorsichtig können sie das verstehen
es kann schon verstehen aber dazu muss
man wissen dass impfstoffe mit zu den am
besten getesteten medikamenten gehören
da werden immer sehr sehr umfangreiche
studien durchgeführt
das wird an sehr vielen personen
getestet und die zulassungen vielleicht
auch eine wichtige information die
zulassung in europa ist eine normale
zulassung für die für jedes medikament
andere länder zum beispiel die usa haben
notfall zulassungen gemacht aber in
deutschland sind da wirklich keine
abkürzungen genommen worden also ist
eine ganz normale reguläre zulassung und
das setzt natürlich auch eine
umfangreiche prüfung der prüfbehörde
voraus jetzt gibt es eine reihe von
argumenten für eine impfung von kindern
vielleicht gehen wir mal ein paar von
ihnen durch die jetzt in der diskussion
sind da ist natürlich zunächst einmal
der schutz der eigenen gesundheit der
kinder
jetzt sagt aber ihre organisation von
der sie vorsitzender sind dass kinder
nur sehr selten schwere krone
erkrankungen haben und sie wollen auch
den eltern also ein bisschen über große
sorgen nehmen und sagen es ist zum
beispiel ein viel höheres risiko dass
kinder ertrinken oder bei einem
verkehrsunfall ums leben kommen als dass
sie an corona sterben das heißt also die
impfung von kindern ist aus ihrer sicht
wichtig aber gar nicht mal so sehr wegen
der gesundheit mit der eigenen
gesundheit der kinder selbst also da
gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche
kinder unterschiedliche patientengruppen
und was wir natürlich ganz besonders im
auge haben sind kinder mit
grunderkrankungen das sind kinder die
sicher und ganz klar von so einer
impfung profitieren würden
bei den anderen kindern war den sonst
gesunden kindern liegt der fall das
sicher anders da ist das risiko sehr
sehr geringen von schweren verläufen von
todesfällen
da die haben ja wirklich nur sehr
vereinzelt gesehen also da muss man
sicher sehr sehr gut auch nochmal
abwägen
die risiken und der nutzen von so einer
impfung wobei man natürlich sagen muss
diese impfungen die ja bisher auch schon
einmal auf der welt geworden ist ist
bisher wirklich mit sehr sehr wenige
nebenwirkungen assoziiert gewesen
was ist mit dem argument dass kinder
geimpft wieder viel mehr am sozialen
leben teilnehmen können dass ihnen ja
doch sehr fehlt das finde ich ein ganz
entscheidender punkt das wäre sicher
auch ein wichtiger grund warum eltern
und kinder eben eine impfung auch sich
für eine impfung entscheiden
und dann gibt es noch ein drittes
argument die so genannte herdenimmunität
also sprich kinder sollten geimpft
werden weil es unter den erwachsenen
jedoch einige gibt die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen und das sozusagen die
kinder dann damit herangezogen werden
damit es am ende reicht wenn man so will
ist das aus ihrer sicht ein gültiges
argument für die impfung von kindern
also da sind 22 dinge zu berücksichtigen
das eine ist wie stark die kinder
wirklich zu herdenimmunität beitragen
ist glaube ich letzten endes nicht so
klar
kinder sind folgen der epidemie scheinen
aber nicht der treiber der der pandemie
zu sein und der andere punkt ist
natürlich dass kinder jetzt nicht auch
herangezogen werden sollen
um wirklich auch wieder die erwachsenen
zu schützen kinder haben jetzt in dieser
pandemie genügend opfer gebracht und ich
denke das darf kein argument sein
was ist mit longo wird also möglichen
folgeschäden langzeitfolge schäden
möglicherweise auch für kinder
also das ist ein neues thema wir haben
darüber
erste informationen es gibt vereinzelt
publikationen wo solche dinge mal
systematisch aufgearbeitet worden sind
für deutschland haben wir noch sehr
wenig daten wenn ich mit kollegen
spreche auch mit den niedergelassenen
kollegen glaube ich dass es in
deutschland bisher kein großes problem
ist das ist aber sicher was was wir auf
dem schirm haben und darüber wie er als
kinderärzte auch weiter forschen müssen
und dass wir gucken müssen aber das ist
glaube ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aus
meiner sicht kein wichtiger grund dass
wir kinder impfen mussten
jetzt gibt es auch manche eltern die
sagen ich würde gern meine kinder
entscheiden lassen ob sie geimpft werden
möchten also ab einem gewissen alter
natürlich wie sehen sie das
also bringt sie wie alles ist sicher gut
größere kinder so was mit einzubeziehen
kinder erleben die pandemie auch mit
bekommen auch mit wie die verläufe sind
die kinder damit teilnehmen zu lassen
ist sicher sinnvoll entscheiden müssen
das aber letzten endes die eltern und
ich finde das nicht gut wenn eltern so
eine verantwortung auch die kinder
abwälzen
professor üben herzlichen dank für das
gespräch keine ursache das gespräch
haben ganz kurz vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet von den kindern jetzt zu
den erwachsenen und deren im funk was da
künftig gelten soll in deutschland damit
beginnt jetzt
es geht um geimpfte und gelesene ihnen
will die bundesregierung möglichst
schnell die grundrechte wiedergeben
man arbeite an all der verordnung mit so
wird nicht großem zeitlichen ehrgeiz die
länder haben ähnliches angekündigt oder
schon umgesetzt
der entwurf für die verordnung sieht vor
dass die betroffenen von ausgangssperren
befreit werden ebenso wie von kontakt
beschränkungen und pflichten keine
ausnahmen sind dagegen bei abstandsgebot
und masken pflicht vorgesehen
unterdessen werden die rufe nach
verstärkten impfungen in sozialen
brennpunkten lauter intensivmediziner
und kommunalpolitiker sprachen sich
unter anderem für mobile teams außerdem
sei mehr aufklärung nötig hintergrund
sind studien nach denen die
infektionszahlen in sozial
benachteiligten stadtteilen höher sind
als in reicheren vierteln in rheinland
pfalz wollen spd grüne und fdp eine
ampelkoalition fortsetzen das gaben ihre
spitzen am nachmittag bekannt
ministerpräsidentin dreyer sprach
angesichts der korona handle me von
einem kraftakt
drei große ziele wolle man nun angehen
ein land pfalz zum führenden
biotechnologie standort ausbauen das
land klimaneutral und die innenstädte
zukunftsfähig machen
am 6 mai sollen die parteitage grünes
licht geben moskau hat sanktionen gegen
acht hochrangige vertreter aus eu
staaten verhängt darunter
parlamentspräsident soli man antwortet
damit auf strafmaßnahmen die brüssel
gegen russische regierungsvertreter
verhängt hatte grund dafür war die
inhaftierung des russischen
kremlkritikers navalny es wäre die erste
wahl seit 15 jahren in den
palästinenser-gebieten gewesen die für
mai geplante parlamentswahl
nun wurde sie auf unbestimmte zeit
verschoben palästinenserpräsident abbas
erklärte die abstimmung könne erst dann
stattfinden wenn die wahlberechtigten
auch in ostjerusalem definitiv ihre
stimme abgeben könnten
israel wolle dafür keine garantie geben
in ramallah gegen hunderte gegen die
entscheidung auf die straße auch der eu
außenbeauftragte borel forderte einen
neuen termin ohne verzögerung nakba
romer ist ein fröhliches fest im
judentum
in der zeit zwischen pessach rundschau
wort die trauer zeit ist ausgesetzt für
picknicks lagerfeuer hochzeiten
seit der vergangenen nacht ist dieser
feiertag verknüpft mit einem unglück
historischer dimension einem der
schlimmsten in der israelischen
geschichte
was als wallfahrt von zehntausenden
streng religiöser juden am berg miron im
norden von israel begann endet als
katastrophe eine massenpanik mit
mindestens 45 toten zu trauern israel
kommen jetzt drängende fragen michael
bewerunge berichtet
ein land in schock und trauer nicht
einmal all ihre toten können sie vor
beginn des schabbats heute beerdigen so
wie es die tradition vorschreibt viele
opfer konnten nicht rechtzeitig
identifiziert werden
heute ist unser aller herz gebrochen
anstatt wie sonst am feiertag lag bei
mehr glücklich zu sein und in meran zu
feiern laufen die menschen mit hängenden
köpfen herum
auch am unglücksort können die menschen
nicht begreifen was dort letzte nacht
geschah zu traumatisch sind die
erlebnisse
ich kam und sah all die toten kinder
das handy von einem kind klingelte
sanitäter packten die leiche des kindes
in einem sack einer von ihnen weinten
was soll ich mit dem handy machen hat er
gefragt in den sack schmeißen es war
furchtbar
dabei hatte gestern alles so fröhlich
und ausgelassen begonnen nach dem harten
corona ja und dem ende der
beschränkungen hatten viele die
wallfahrt nach miron herbeigesehnt erste
planungen sahen 10.000 teilnehmer vor
doch an die hunderttausend orthodoxe
kamen die zum teil provisorischen
anlagen sind diesem ansturm nicht
gewachsen
an einem steilen abgang kommt es zur
katastrophe
die menge kommt ins rutschen menschen
fallen stolpern übereinander
panik bricht aus es gibt über 150
verletzte die meisten toten sind wohl
erstickt
wir wurden nach links und rechts
geschoben ich bemerkte menschen unter
mir die nicht mehr atmete andere
schrieben dass sie keine luft bekommen
dann verstummten die rufe retter kommen
schlecht durch ein- und ausgänge sind
offenbar falsch dimensioniert die
menschen laufen in eine tödliche falle
der boden war aus metall und sehr
glitschig jemand rutschte aus und dann
fielen die anderen über ihn
ministerpräsident netanjahu verspricht
am unglücksort aufklärung aber er und
die polizei werden von einer
aufgebrachten menge als mörder
beschimpft ihr vorwurf die polizei habe
ausgänge verriegelt oder nicht
rechtzeitig geöffnet
die hauptursache war aber wohl eher dass
zu viele menschen auf das gelände
gelassen wurden beobachter werfen
deshalb netanjahu vor seine politischen
partner bei den orthodoxen wie so oft
mit zugeständnisse bei den
teilnehmerzahlen hof ihr zu haben
man muss ein paar tage zurück gehen um
zu sehen wie sich die minister geradezu
darum gestritten haben vor allem der
premierminister
wer den verdienst einheimsen darf die
meisten leute für diese veranstaltung
zuzulassen
präsident replay zündete heute kerzen
für die opfer an jetzt sei die zeit ihre
familien zu umarmen und denen zu helfen
die nach ihren angehörigen suchten
für die hinterbliebenen ist es die zeit
der trauer die zeit für antworten muss
danach kommen eine katastrophe mit
ansage schreiben israels zeitungen seit
jahren heißt es dass hunderttausende an
so einem ort nicht zu verantworten sind
dieses jahr kamen warnungen dazu wegen
der extremen ansteckungsgefahr
die wallfahrt erinnert unter anderem an
eine pandemie vor 2000 jahren in die
deutsche politik jetzt wo die cdu basis
im süden von thüringen der berliner
parteizentrale die grenzen ihrer macht
zeigt die lokale cdu schickt seit heute
offiziell hans-georg maßen als ihren
bundestagskandidaten ins rennen obwohl
der weder aus südthüringen kommt noch
besonders aufgefallen wäre als einer der
sich um die gegend besonders bemüht der
mann der als verfassungsschutzchef erst
massiv in die kritik geraten war und
dann in den einstweiligen ruhestand
versetzt wurde gilt den cdu mann rund um
suhl als hoffnungsträger für die cdu
parteizentrale und den kanzlerkandidaten
ist eher ein problem
melanie haack und daniela sonntag
berichtet
nun ist es amtlich hans-georg maßen ist
für die bundestagswahl nominiert
der rheinländer ist direktkandidat der
cdu in südthüringen
hier soll der ex verfassungsschutzchef
der als rechtsausleger der cdu gilt die
wähler zurückholen die an die afg
verloren gegangen sind schlichtweg den
wahlkreis retten
der politische gegner ist grün-rot
tiefrot und die afd
diese parteien müssen im wahlkampf
bekämpft werden und nicht wir nicht
gegen uns und da muss man das in berlin
und erfurt auch ertragen lernen dass man
möglichst breit aufgestellt in diesem
nicht ganz einfache bundestags bei gibt
die cdu-führung in bund und land hätte
gern auf maßen verzichtet zu groß die
angst mit dem streng konservativen
wählerschichten in der mitte zu
verlieren ein riss zwischen den cdu
lagern der sich in thüringen besonders
deutlich zeigt hier hatte die cdu
gemeinsam mit der fdp musk emmerich
gewählt und die afg ist stärker als sie
wie also reagieren viele hatten erst auf
märz dann auf söder gesetzt maßen für
die südthüringer einen ersatz
besonders im osten punkten offenbar
kandidaten wie sie diese wörter struktur
ist dahingehend anders ausgeprägt als
wir hier viel größere erfahrungen
natürlich aufgrund der wende mit
transformation mit sozialen wandel haben
sie haben in ihrem leben schon so starke
einschnitte und veränderungen gehabt
dass ich sie jetzt eher danach dürstet
das alles möglich so bleibt wie es ist
dass es bewahrt wird dass es konserviert
wird willi fischer ist 21 der nachwuchs
der thüringer cdu sie kennt nur eine
kanzlerin und hätte sich nun markus
söder gewünscht mit der wahl armin
laschet zum kanzlerkandidaten hoffen wie
sie viele an der ostdeutschen basis auf
einen klaren kurs
wir haben zu lange darüber geredet wer
für uns stehen jetzt muss diese person
auch sagen wofür steht die cdu
warum soll ich cdu am 26 september
wählen
und genau da müssen wir hinkommen wie
thüringen wird auch mecklenburg
vorpommern im herbst landtag und
bundestag
für letzteren geht georg günther von der
jungen union ins rennen in dem wahlkreis
in dem bislang die kanzlerin antrat
es ist eine chance
es ist sicherlich auch eine bürde auch
sein verband setzte auf söder auf seine
themen wie günther sagt dass es nun
laschet ist hat die junge union
geschluckt begeistert waren sie nicht
jetzt arrangieren sie sich auch ihnen
sitzt die fdp festlegen so viele
herausforderungen vor uns
und gerade hier vor ort wird es wichtig
sein antworten zu finden wie wir
arbeitsplätze natürlich hier vor ort
schaffen die wir natürlich auch das
thema bildung voran bekommen ein
wahlprogramm hat armin laschet noch
nicht dafür hat er jetzt friedrich merz
ins team geholt die große hoffnung im
osten
jetzt wolle man nach vorn schauen und
hier macht kasse weiter mit deutlichen
worten hat verdi-chef wernicke
handelskonzerne kritisiert die von der
korona pandemie profitiert haben
drogerieketten und baumärkte hätten sich
so wörtlich dumm und dämlich verdient
für die mitarbeiterin habe es aber nicht
einmal einen feuchten händedruck gegeben
so wernicke im zdf
außerdem forderte er die große koalition
auf das geplante gesetz zur
einschränkung befristeter
arbeitsverträge auf den weg zu bringen
das komplette interview sehen sie im
heute-journal update um zwanzig nach
zwölf und schon jetzt in der zdf
mediathek in den metropolen steigen die
immobilienpreise jahr seit jahren rasant
dagegen ging die kurve im ländlichen
raum nur leicht nach oben wenn überhaupt
das hat sich nun offenbar geändert was
heißt dass valerie haller und was steckt
dahinter
dahinter steckt ein trend der sich durch
corona noch verstärkt hat die menschen
ziehen schon länger raus aus der stadt
in den speckgürtel weil dort die preise
aber auch schon stark gestiegen sind
wird nun das land immer attraktiver mit
der folge dass auch dort der wohnraum
immer teurer wird das gilt für weite
teile deutschlands besonders ausgeprägt
ist das aber in bayern stiegen die
quadratmeterpreise in münchen
vergangenes jahr um sechs prozent machen
es in miesbach fast zehn prozent
in bad tölz und sogar im 90 kilometer
entfernten garmisch jeweils 15 prozent
vor allem familien zieht es raus aufs
land
die hauspreise steigen praktisch
unabhängig davon wie weit die nächste
metropole entfernt ist ein trendbruch
meint der branchenverband zentraler
immobilien der dazu gerade eine studie
in auftrag gegeben hat die korona
pandemie wirkt nun wie ein verstärker
sie hat vielen menschen die vorteile des
wohnens in den eigenen vier wänden vor
augen geführt und durch das vermehrte
arbeiten im home office sind fachkräfte
auch nicht mehr unbedingt an die großen
städte gebunden
da heißt es für einige nun natur idol
stadt großstadthektik dank an die börse
valerie bleiben wir bei der wirtschaft
das bruttoinlandsprodukt ist im ersten
quartal dieses jahres gesunken um 17
prozent im vergleich zum vorquartal
als hauptgrund sieht das statistische
bundesamt die korona maßnahmen
sie hätten den konsum gebremst während
der export die konjunktur gestützt habe
für die kommenden monate erwarten
ökonomen unternehmen gute geschäfte
vorausgesetzt der kampf gegen die
pandemie ist erfolgreich und das hier
ist nichts für schwache nerven in
portugal eröffnet am wochenende die
längste fußgänger hängebrücke der welt
die ersten durften schon jetzt das 560
meter lange konstrukt ihren 175 meter
über dem fluss piva gut zu sehen durch
das metallgitter im boden für ihren mut
werden die besucher belohnt mit einem
spektakulären blick über das
naturparadies südöstlich von porto viele
jahrzehnte lang haben wir uns in
deutschen museen kunstschätze angesehen
die geraubt wurden in berlin zum
beispiel 440 bronson die eigentlich den
herrscher hof der edo völker schmückten
im königreich benin heute nigeria
das britische militär hatte den palast
1897 geplündert und die kunstwerke als
trophäe in alle welt verscherbelt jetzt
wollen sie zurück dorthin wo sie
herkommen und wo sie erschaffen wurden
und damit kommt bewegung in ein
die diskussion die auch schon jahrzehnte
alt ist um die rückgabe afrikanischer
kulturgüter
es ist ein thema das nicht nur
museumsdirektoren und außenpolitiker
interessieren muss es könnte zum
wendepunkt werden bei der aufarbeitung
von kolonialgeschichte stephan
merseburger atemberaubend schön sind sie
meister werke afrikanischer kunst lieben
ihn bremsen
doch die preziosen haben einen makel sie
sind raubkunst aus der kolonialzeit mehr
als 1000 davon besitzen die deutschen
museen ab 2022 so beschlossen politik
und museen gestern gemeinsam soll es so
die amtliche formulierung zu
substanziellen rückgaben kommen
es geht darum dass wir unsere moralische
und historische verantwortung wahrnehmen
und nicht mehr nur darüber reden sondern
tatsächlich rückgaben in gang setzen
hierhin sollen sie zurückkehren benin
city im heutigen nigeria ein museum
westafrikanischer kunst wird hier
entstehen das braucht zeit geeignete
depots aber werden wohl bis 2022 fertig
früher war benin ein königreich 1897
hatten britische kolonialtruppen bei
einer blutigen strafexpedition den
palast geplündert die erbeuteten großen
wurden weiter an europäische museen
verkauft die verhandlungen über
rückgaben laufen schon länger in benin
city erreichen wir ein mitglied der
stiftung die die großen übernehmen soll
per skype die großen sind wichtiger teil
unseres kulturellen erbes teil unserer
geschichte und tradition
man kann sie mit den werken europäischer
meister vergleichen
michelangelo da vinci oder picasso
die großen sind längst zu einem symbol
für koloniales unrecht geworden weltweit
kritik und rückgabeforderungen wurden
immer lauter vor fünf jahren kündigte
der französische präsident makro an
während des kolonialismus geraubte kunst
an afrikanische länder zurückzugeben
die voraussetzungen dafür wurden in
einem bericht festgehalten
mitverfasserin ist die kunsthistorikerin
bénédicte vor sie hat die rückgabe
debatte maßgeblich geprägt ich stelle
fest dass die zivilgesellschaft mit
ihren aufforderungen die kolonialzeit
aufzuarbeiten und die wissenschaft die
sehr bemüht war historisch belegte
fakten zu diesem themen freizulegen und
zu publizieren dass beide sich
durchgesetzt haben
gegen den widerstand der museen gerade
in berlin so beharrlich wie lange haben
sich deutsche museen gegen rückgabe
forderungen gesträubt die ersten aus
nigeria in berlin gab es 1972 auch im
humboldt forum im berliner schloss
sollen die bronson bald gezeigt werden
und jetzt wir wollen weiterhin bei den
bronson natürlich in berlin im
humboldt-forum mag sich ja auch an
anderen deutschen museen zeigen aber das
wollen wir im einverständnis mit der
nigerianischen seite tun unter welchen
bedingungen des möglich ist klar ist wer
die großen zeigt muss die damit
verbundene blutige geschichte erzählt
die bienen bronson wären nur der anfang
ein präzedenzfall sie könnten zum
fundament werden für eine neue
europäische afrikanische zusammenarbeit
bei kultur und erinnerung und damit
entlasten wir sie in diesen acht und in
den mai
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der kälteste april
seit den 80er jahren liegt hinter uns
und das lag hauptsächlich daran dass wir
die meiste zeit eine nördliche strömung
hatten
man sagt auch dazu mehr regional wenn
sie entlang der langen gerade ist und
diese wetterlagen mit mehr regionalen
strömungen und festhängenden
wettersystem geholfen sich in den
letzten jahren und das wird auf die
erhitzung des planeten zurückgeführt so
die wissenschaft und dadurch würden
extremwetterereignisse begünstigt und
dementsprechend war der april also
deutlich zu kalt kein widerspruch zur
globalen erhitzung schauen wir auf das
wetter da ziehen tiefs durch und bringt
kräftigen regen mit und der ist sehr
willkommen denn es war immer im april
auch zu trocken und bereits in der nacht
wird es regnen im westen wird es aber
allmählich auflockert und die
temperaturen dort sinken bis auf minus
zwei grad richtung eifel und 8 grad im
südosten deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf gibt es nach norden hin
regen richtung erzgebirge und auch bis
richtung schleswig holstein aber im
südwesten kommt neuer regen auf und er
überquert und dann allmählich in der
nacht auf sonntag sonntag nach nordosten
hin und das bei höchsten temperaturen
von 19 grad im südosten deutschlands
sonst bei 11 bis 16 mit zehn grad an der
ostsee ist es am kühlsten ja und am
sonntag also viel regen aus südwest bis
14 grad und danach wird es wärmer
dienstag gibt es sogar sturm damit ein
schöner abend